よろしくお願いします
今日はあの 一応 33ページから始まります
ブッダの今まで説明したのは
あのまあ 54種類の心を説明いたしましたが
その 54種類の心がこの欲界に入るんだと言ってるんです
で 仏教では欲というのは
あの まあ欲界 カーマローカとパーリ語で言うんですね
で それまあそんなにあの欲界と言ったっても
欲の欲がっている世界という意味じゃないんです
まあ言葉はすごくいい加減で言えばいい加減なんです
この欲界という専門用語が
で 定義がしていて 欲というのはこの物事を我々認識するときは
この眼耳鼻舌身というこのチャンネルを通って色声香味触という情報を認識する
だから欲と欲界と言うんですね
ですから この定義はややこしくて
用語はすごいいい加減で
なんで欲界と言うかというと
そこから欲が生まれるんだから
欲が生まれる原因になるんだから
ただそれだけ 例えば我々物事を知っているという場合は
目があるんですね 目があるんだから
目を通して物事を知っている
ですから 私たちの認識に
私がここにいる 私が偉い人だ
偉くない人だとか ありとあらゆる認識が生まれる
その認識が生まれるために
私の目が結構働きをしてくれるんですね
目があって そこに世界があると知っているし
ここに私がいると知っているし
ですから 目というものは大事な働きをしてくれている
そこで目を通して認識が生まれる
それで目に入る情報は決まっていて
いわゆる色と言って いろいろ光やら形やらそういうものしか目に入りませんし
それによって我々の心の中で欲やら怒りやら生まれる可能性はいくらでもあります
ですから 欲が生まれる可能性あるんだから欲界と言うんだけど
別にこのそれ以上の意味がないんです
とにかく欲界の心っていうのは
眼耳鼻舌身に関係ある心に欲界というんです
だから欲界の心は全部 54種類がございますけど
で カーマーヴァチャラチットと言うんですね
で カーマーヴァチャラという欲界に
アーヴァチャラというのはもう歩いて行き渡っているという
欲界に行き渡っている心が 54種類があるんだと
で そこでその中に決して欲張っている人々の悪い人の心が 54あるという意味じゃなくて
眼耳鼻舌身に関係ある眼耳鼻舌身の中で行き渡っている心が 54種類がありますよということだけなんですね
ですから その中に阿羅漢たちに生まれる心も入ってるんですね
例えばお釈迦様が笑っている時は
正喜心という特別な心が生まれるんだと言ってるんですね
それはお釈迦様の心なんですけど
それも欲界に入ってるんです
なぜならば お釈迦様が微笑したっても
これは誰かを見て何かを対象を感じて考えてやっていることだから
欲界には変わりはありませんし
そこで阿羅漢になった悟った人々は行動している
それは完全に善行為なんですね
悪いことをしませんだから
でもそれも欲界に入れてるんです
優捨心として 善も悪でも何もないんだから
我々から見れば善行為に見えるだけで
善も悪でもない それは優捨心ですから
阿羅漢たちの心も欲界の中に入ってるんですが
決して欲の心という意味じゃなくて
その時その人の体 眼耳鼻舌身として認識が回転しているという意味だけなんですね
ですから そういうので欲界と言うんです
ですから それは仏教のそういうふうな次元なんですね
欲の次元 で 仏教を勉強する場合
ちょっと面倒くさいのは
そういうこの曖昧というか
いい加減なところが結構あるんですね
あまり厳密に科学的に解釈しながらしようとしない
どこかで抜けちゃうというか
我々やっぱりヨーロッパ的な知識から見れば
もうしっかりしてほしいところ
僕個人的な好き嫌いで言ったってもね
まあしっかりしなさいというところは言いたいところありますけど
で なんかどこかでまあ
そういう曖昧に感じるところはあるんですね
ですから 欲界 欲の次元と言いながら
そこに阿羅漢たちの心を入れている
やっぱりその訳がそれなりにあるんですね
阿羅漢であろうが 目で物を見ると眼耳鼻舌身に頼ってるんだから
欲界の心であって そこに煩悩がないと
と言うんですね いわゆる認識の次元は欲の次元
欲というのは言葉がおかしいんです
言葉さえ捨てちゃえばいいんです
いわゆるもう普通に 使う
例えば三次元だと言ったような
三次元の心だと そういう風に言った方がなんとなくわかりますけどね
阿羅漢たちであろうが
普通の人でも三次元的な心やとか
でも心には三次元 四次元とかは言えませんだからね
次元は使いませんだからね
次元論を使うのは物質の世界で
ですから ただもうやたらにこの次元という言葉も使ってはいけないんです
人間というのは本当に騙されやすいんだから
ある宗教ではもう三次元
四次元 六次元 八次元 十二十三次元
十四次元とか偉そうなこと言ってますね
そこで僕もなんで十五次元
十六次元 十八次元 百八十次元とかないんですかと
ただ数えるだけではもうバカな連中は次元はわからないんですよ
人間に理解できるのは三次元だけなんです
三次元にいるんだから
二次元というのは頭で観察できるんだけど
体験は不可能なんです
例えば数学的には点 ポイント
ポイント 点というものは存在するんですね
でも絶対我々の経験ではポイント点というものは存在しないんです
ポイントは描くことは絶対できないんです
描けません 描けませんし
見ることもできないし
それなのに我々の頭の中でポイントは存在する
それから一直線と言うんですか
このストレートライン
そういうものは数学では散々使ってるでしょうに
でもそれは決して体験できないし
描くこともできないんです
で 我々描くのはストレートラインではなくて
長い 何て言いますか 細長い四角いやつ
何て言いますか 長方形
長方形なんですね いくら細くたっても長方形には変わりはありませんだから
線は描けません ですから
次元というのは そんな我々三次元に我々に二次元さえ理解できないんだから
まあいい加減やたらに使うのは
単なる頭の人を騙すために言ってることで
何の意味もないんです
まあわかってないということはね
そういう次元論を語る人々は全然わかってないってことはわかりますけど
しょうがないです まあそんな話はどうでもいいんだけど
で 欲の次元 欲ではなくて
この眼耳鼻舌身の次元はこれ
で これから説明するのはルーパヴァチャラという心なんですね
[背景音楽]ルーパ・アヴァチャラ・チッタというところなんです
これは日本語で色界と言うんですね
界は助文かもしれませんだけど
まあアヴァチャラっていうのはその何かの領域に行き渡っているという意味なんです
ですから ルーパという次元に色は物質ですけどね
物質の次元に行き渡っている心っていう意味なんです
そうすると欲界も入りますよ
だからなんかこの言葉にしたっても
ちょっと用語として まあどうかなと
わかります？ルーパアヴァチャラ
ルーパは物質の世界で
アヴァチャラっていうのは物質の次元に行き渡っている心って意味なんです
で カーマアヴァチャラっていうのはまた物質ですから
もう眼耳鼻舌身の次元だから
そこに行き渡っているということで
眼耳鼻舌身に行き渡っている心はカーマアヴァチャラで
物質の世界で行き渡っている
行き渡っている心はルーパアヴァチャラと言ったってもダブってるんですよ
この用語が いわゆるルーパアヴァチャラの中にカーマアヴァチャラ入ってるんですね
ですから ヨーロッパ的な学問の用語定義を作る時は
それは哲学では欠点だと言っちゃうんです
哲学では 定義論としては
もし皆様方はこの普通の哲学ですか
哲学と論理学と それの中に出てくるこの定義論がありますね
ものにどうやって定義するべきかと
定義論なんか見ると これは大きな欠点なんですね
いわゆるルーパアヴァチャラという言葉はすごく大きくて
で カーマアヴァチャラとルーパアヴァチャラで区別しちゃうと区別できない
ルーパアヴァチャラの中にカーマアヴァチャラあるようになっちゃうんですね
でもそれは欠点かもしれませんだけど
言葉だけ見ると で 我々はまたこれを定義して
その問題は解決する アビダンマでは
定義して解決するならば
この言葉自体は大した意味がないということになっちゃうんですね
ただの区別するためのラベルだけであって
ですから このあまり言葉に厳密にとらわれてはいけないんです
そうすると仏教も理解できなくなっちゃうんです
言葉は言葉で まあほどほどに使うと
ですから仏教でも 例えば私
自分という言葉は抜きに喋れませんよ
言葉で喋ってるんだから
私はあなたに言ったんではないかと
その話を聞いたあの相手が
あ あなたは私を認めた
私という存在を認めたんだと
それは仏教でどうなるものかと言っちゃうと
もう答えられないし もうまあ一つぶん殴った方が一番早いんですね
いい加減そんな話にならないんだから
まあそういう言葉使うがなくちゃい
使う なんて言いますか
使う 使わないでどうやってね
あの会話できますか？これストーリーがあります
インドである森の中であるお坊さんたち二人かな
ずっともう住んでるんですね
そこでもうその二人でもう住んでいて
そこでその森にある神様がいたんだと
その神様がこの二人がものすごく清らかで
もう何の欲もなくそこで住んでいるし
まあなんとかちょっと托鉢してきて
そこでまあ静かに平和でいる
で この二人がおそらく阿羅漢だよと思っちゃうんですね
思って神様大変ありがたくて
自分の森の中に聖者二人が住んでるんだから
大変ありがたいではないかと思っていて
そこである日 そのお坊さん二人が話しているのは聞こえたんですね
どういう話かというと
まあそこで私はなんとかなんとかどうか
あなたはなんとかなんとか
そういう風にこの二人だからね
私とあなたという言葉を使っていたんですね
そこであの神様ががっかりしたんです
で ああ 私はこの二人が阿羅漢だと思っていたんだけど
やっぱり私という言葉を使っているし
あなたという言葉を使っている
やっぱりまだまだ自我を全て捨ててないんだと
がっかりしちゃったんですね
その神もものすごい大馬鹿者だと思いますけど
で 仏教の話は知ってるんですね
話だけは 仏教は自我をなくすこと
これ大変なことだと そういう修行を教えていて
完成した人は自我はないんだと
で このお坊さん二人が私とあなたという言葉を使ってるんだから
もうやっぱりまだまだ自我があるんだと
言葉だけにとらわれてるんですね
そこでまあ神様に力ないんです
本当に阿羅漢かないかという探すぐらいの能力はないんです
まあどうせ聖者の心は読めませんだから
でお釈迦様に会ってその話を言うんですね
私はあの二人は本当に悟ったと思っていたんだけど
まだそうではないんだと
だからお釈迦様にものすごい怒られるんですね
この言葉にとらわるのは
そういうバカがいるんだと
言葉にとらわれていろいろなことを考えちゃうんだと
それは言葉っていうのはワールドバランス
いわゆるこの世の中の常識だけですと
コモンセンス ごく普通なコモンセンスで
聖者であろうがなかろうが関係なく言葉使いますよと
そんなことでもなんか気になっちゃうのは
まあまあとんでもない愚か者だと
いわゆる言葉の使い方を理解してほしいということで
もう神様には散々叱られたんだけど
いわゆるあの二人のお坊様が本当に阿羅漢でしたんです
阿羅漢で悟っていて 自我はなかったんです
自我がなくても あの 私は水くみに行きますよと
ということで この生滅変化しているこの色声香触味法音が水という地水火風
なんとか何とかもうくみに
バカバカしいでしょ そういうのは私は水くみに行きますよと
だからまあそこら辺はまあ気をつけてほしいということなんです
で ある女性の信者さんでしたけど
あの悟ってるんです もうまあ出家ではなくて
在家なんです ですから
不還果までしか悟れないんですね
阿羅漢になったらもう在家で生活できないんです
ですから この不還果まで悟って
禅定があって 大変素晴らしい女性の方でしたけど
まあなんか鳥を飼っていたんですね
ペット そこをあの 自分のペットにもできるだけいろいろ仏教を教えていたんだと
そこでこのペットを他の鳥に捕らわれちゃったんです
捕まれちゃった 捕まったところで
この女の人が自分のペットだから
いろいろ石を投げたり
いろんなことをして とにかくもうまたなんて言いますか
その場合はもう 取り戻しちゃったんですね
取り戻したら どうせ怪我して色々あって
そこで鳥にこう聞くんですね
もうやっぱり死ぬのは別にどうってことないんだけど
まあまあ悟っているんだから
それを心配しているのは
自分飼ってるペットがどんな心で死ぬかということは心配なんですね
もし悪い心で死んじゃったら地獄に落ちるんだから怖いとか
大体捕らわれちゃったらものすごく恐怖感と怒りが生まれてくるんですね
恐怖と怒りは同じものなんです
ですから その怒りで死んじゃったらね
せっかく自分が飼っていたペットは地獄に落ちておいしくないんだから
噂はそれを聞くんだそうです
あなたはあの鳥に捕まれた時は何を考えていたんですか？あ
その時私はこの色受想行識
色受 まあルーパ ヴェーダナー
サンニャ サンカーラ ヴィンニャーナという五蘊を
また他のルーパ ヴェーダナー
サンニャ サンカーラ ヴィンニャーナで五蘊に運ばれているんだと
そう思って落ち着いていたんだと
で その場合は私は殺されていると思うのは間違いであって
私は殺されかけているんだ
食べられるんだと これからは
それで恐怖感生まれて煩悩が生まれると
その瞬間で正しく私ということはそこ存在しないんだと
単なる色受想行識というエネルギーの流れであって
それまた違う色受想行識とエネルギーの流れにもうつなげていくだけですと
何のこともないんだと
で 雨が降って川の水が多くなったって
別に大した大胆なことじゃないんだから
そんな感じで見るだけで
ですから その仏教の用語的な言葉を使う場合がありまして
まあ一般的な言葉を使う場合があります
それぐらいは聞き分けというか
知って分けておかなくちゃいけないんですね
そこをやってないんだから
あれとあれの誤解が生まれるんですね
なんで仏教ではいっぱい宗派が出てくるかというと
一つの原因はこの言葉の問題なんです
あのバカみたく言葉が間違ってるんです
で そんなこと言ったら怒られますけど
僕らから見れば言葉は間違ってることは完全にわかるんですね
例えば原始経典ではお釈迦様には小学者と言うんです
弟子たちには阿羅漢と言うんです
それは区別するための言葉なんです
そこでお釈迦様に対するものすごい尊敬と敬意とあって
もう大変 あの 何と言いますか
信仰深い心なんですね
お釈迦様に使っている言葉を自分で使わない
失礼だから ただそれだけ
でもお釈迦様が私も阿羅漢であり
あなた方も阿羅漢であると言うんです
それはお釈迦様先生が自分の弟子たちはもう完璧になったよと表彰状をあげることだから
あなた方も私も同じですよと言ってるんだから
初期仏教学問的に言えば
小学者 阿羅漢 仏陀イコールなんです
そこで言葉だけ見る人にとっては
お釈迦様の弟子たちがいわゆる沙門ですか
そういう沙門という弟子たちが阿羅漢だけなレベルなんですね
仏陀だけ小学者なんですね
なるほど 阿羅漢たちがまだ仏陀になってない
一番偉いのは仏陀だから
我々は仏陀にならなくちゃいけない
阿羅漢というのは完全たる悟りじゃないんだと
もうえらいことを言っちゃうんですね
だからそこはもう完全に全くバカバカらしい概念で
そこを間違ったんだから
言葉使い方は とんでもない宗派が
いろいろと我々ものが生まれてきたんですね
それでせっかく修行して悟る人々の悟りはそれできちんと終わると
なぜならば聖者否定しているでしょ
阿羅漢たちは不完全だというのは
世の中で隅の中でものすごい強烈な罪一つなんです
もし聖者を否定して貶したこと経験があったならば
その人はどれほど頑張っても悟りの境地に行かないんです
あの隅で引っ張られちゃうんです
だからその人々はいい加減に言葉操っちゃって
いわゆるウラニウムは何も知らないバカがウラニウムと遊んだことと同じくなっちゃうんです
触ってはいけないものだから
ウラニウムはいくら役に立ったっても
触るもんじゃないんです
あれは 近寄るものじゃないんです
そういうことで言葉を誤って大変な
まあ我々はテーラワーダの初期仏教の道徳観から言うなれば
大変な罪を犯してるんですね
罪を犯したらいいんだけど
せっかく自分の心を清らかにする道も閉ざしてしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 哲学だけ 頭の回転だけ
難しい膨大な もう何て言いますか
サタサハスリー・プラクニャー・パーラミターというぐらい
サタサハスリーというのは Hundred thousand という
あの 100万 え？ 10万 10
万とか20万とかそれぐらいの偈文で増やして増やして
で プラクニャーは何ですかと
膨大な量なんですね それもお坊さんたちは読まないんです
法事というものがあります
それでサーッと本を開けて
また閉じて それだけで終わっちゃうんです
それで読んだことになるんだと
すごい徳があるんだと
お寺に行ってみてください
法事という 1年に一回ぐらい儀式があるんです
別にそれは別にそれでいいんですけど
宗教儀式としては別に悪いわけじゃないんだけど
結局それぐらいで終わってしまうんですよ
読んでも何々般若 何々般若とか何ですかだから
ただ初めから間違っただけのことで
何の意味もないんです
ある人は般若は 10種類に分けたならば
僕は 20種類に分けて見せますよ
人が 20種類に分けちゃったら
僕は 40種類に分けて分けて見せますよ
ただの言葉の遊びだから
大般若ありますと言えば
僕は最大般若ありますと言えますから
もし人が最大般若と言って
僕は超越最大般若ありますと言えますから
何のこともないんです
それなりの定義もできるし
ですから 仏教を勉強すると
そういう哲学のこの弱さということもよく見えてくるんです
哲学にもやられません
何者にも自分を あの 何と言いますか
やられないというしっかりした状態が出てくる
だからって自分が硬いわけでもないんです
例えば 人はどんな話を聞いても自分が変化しませんというのはもうかなり頑固なんですね
人の話を聞かないということだから
そうじゃないんです ものすごい柔軟性があって
あまりにも柔軟性だから
何も自分で概念を持たないだけなんです
何も持たない あまりにも徹底的な柔軟性だから
人の話をよく理解できる
そういうふうな心が出来上がるんですよ
ですから 何の怖がる必要ないんです
仏教を勉強することでは
私は片っ端から人の概念を壊しますけど
だからといってそれは決して失礼に人に攻撃することでもなく
ないんです ただ 我々の心をより大きいスケールに持つため
持っていくための働きで
それによって仏教を聞く人は頑固になるかというと
全く違い かえって逆になるだけなんです
頑固さを捨てるだけなんです
言葉の概念つけてつけて言っちゃうと
頭の中に それで頭が硬くなっちゃうんです
まあそういうことで ですから
この定義の問題 あまりもういつでもぶつかりますけど
まあ今日からルーパヴァチャラということで
ルーパヴァチャラの定義もそういうことで
ちょっとあの まあただ一つの言葉だけですというぐらいで理解してもいいし
でも今まで言ったのは眼耳鼻舌身に関係ある世界の心
ですから そこでこういう問題があるんです
眼耳鼻舌身の場合は 自然的に心が生まれるんです
何もしなくても 目があると見える
見える見えたものについて考える
別にそれに訓練必要ですか？いりません
耳があるならば 音があるならば聞こえる
聞こえた音について考える
それは誰にでもできる
生命であるならば すべての生命にできる
ですから基本的な です
何の努力もなし 自然的な状態なんです
どんな生命にも眼耳鼻舌身意という六つのこの窓口の六つも
あるいはいくつかついてるんです
眼耳鼻舌身意六つもないというならば
ただの物体で生命ではありません
だから仏教で生命というのは認識するものを認識できる働きに
生命というだけの生命というんですね
その定義でも このある他の我々
一般的に魂や私がああだこうだいう
この宗教的な形而上学的な感覚を捨てちゃうんです
すごい科学的なドライにドライ
ものすごくドライかもしれませんだけど
ただ物体でも構いません
認識しているならば それは生命ですと
ですから ある物体にある日認識機能が入ったんだと
入ったら我々は何のことなく
それは生命ですと 新しい生命が誕生しましたというんです
そういうことで 仏教では人が生まれる
場合は 4つの なんて言いますか
方法があるんだと 一つはこの化生と言うんですね
いきなり現れる それ神々とか
あの日本語の言葉はあまりわかりませんだけど
一応化生といって それはアビダンマもそれから出てくるものなんです
で 神々とかいきなり現れる
その時に身体の心も一片に現れるんだと
もう一つはこの卵から生まれると
そういうこのアンデジャと言うんです
で だからもう一つの生まれ方っていうのは
このお腹の中で まあどんどん成長して
それから生まれるんだと
いわゆる完全たる状態がどのようにできるかと
化生の場合はいきなり完全たる体が出てきちゃう
ある生命の場合は卵としていて
徐々に完全たる姿になって出てくる
ある場合はお腹の中に住んでいて
そこで体を大きく ちゃんともう完全にして貰ってから外へ出ると
もう 4番目は産成別といって
あるところで物質が固まってあって
そこに心が活動し始まる
いわゆる母親も誰も要りません
で 物質がある  なんて言いますか
変化していて そこでそこに生命が誕生できるような環境が出来上がっちゃう
そこで生命が誕生し始めちゃうと
そういう 4種類っているんですね
ですから その なんとなく昔の風な知識で言えば
なんか嘘っぽく聞こえるかもしれませんだけど
現代的な科学的に考えたって
もし科学者がありとあらゆる DNA を作ったりして
科学的にいろいろな合成して合成したところででも誕生は生まれる可能性はあるんです
いまだいまだの技術ではできませんだけど
生まれる可能性はあるんです
昔から仏教では 4種類に分けてるんです
ですから だから科学発展して
試験管で新しい命を誕生しましたと
だから仏教は嘘やと 仏教だったら人が死んでどこかで生まれ変わると言ってるでしょうと
でも科学者が新しい生命を作ったんだからで
そんなことで仏教はもう負けません
遠い昔からちゃんと こういう 4つの方法がありますよと言ってるんだから
ですから この生命には基本的に付いている能力は認識すること
それは眼耳鼻舌身という 4つの 6つのチャネルを通して外界を認識する
それは生命ということであって
尊いという神に作られた神に息が
何て言いますか 吹き込まれたんだから
生命とか魂あるとか そういう風な話はない
科学的な話しかないんです
なぜならば 人間にだけ人間は
あの 何て言いますか 塵で作って
それから命を吹き込んだと
だから人間には魂があるんだとというと
じゃあ動物の魂がないということになってしまっちゃうんですね
そこそれを信じたっても
その中で論理がないとわかるんですね
なぜならば 人間が出来上がるためには
誰かが塵を集めて魂を吹き込まなくちゃいけないであるならば
なぜ動物を作る場合はまた塵を集めて魂を吹き込まなくちゃいけないんですか
動物のことを何も言わないで
で 創造論を語っちゃうんですね
だからそれは本当は全くいい加減な話なんです
人間作る場合は塵で作ったというならば
動物も同じ過程で作らなくちゃいけない
動物も呼吸してご飯餌食べて生きてるんだから
人間と同じくもう魂は吹き込まなくちゃいけないんです
動物には魂がなしと ですからもう何のことなく
あ おかしい話だと理解できるんですけど
頑固に未だに信じてるんです
信じる人々はね ですから
そういうふうに この 別にそういう宗教批判ではなくて
この考え方の誤りというかね
そういうふうに考えると
そういう欠点がありますよと
それだけ理解していけばいいんです
ですから 仏教では最初から生命は生命で
人間も生命で 動物も生命で
何の変わりもないんだと
なぜならば人間も認識するし
動物も物事を認識するし
そういう科学的なアプローチで喋っちゃうんですと
ですから 力強いというのは力強い
じゃあ で まあ今度はルーパ・ヴァーチャナの説明に入ります
で 今まで言ったような基本的に回転する心と違って
違う心の回転はルーパ・ヴァーチャナの回転なんです
いわゆるごく一般的に誰にでも生まれる心ではありません
我々に今生まれている心は犬猫にも生まれているんです
犬猫はものを見て考えているんだから
でも 人間にも自然的には生まれません
誰にでも自然的には生まれません
ある特別な訓練によって生まれる特別な心
ここでルーパ・ヴァーチャナと呼ぶんです
いわゆるある特別な訓練によってする特別な認識
そこで特別な訓練ですから
これにはマハー・チッタとも言うんです
マハッガタ・チッタと言うんです
書きものは持ってこなくちゃいけないんだ
全部今消えてる マハッガタ・チッタと言うんですね M
A H A G G A T A C I T T A
マハッガタ・チッタ マハっていうのは
まあよく聞いたことがある
馴染みのある 日本語でもマカというふうに言っていますから
大という 大きいという
ガタっていうのは一達という意味で
いわゆる大きくなったという意味なんですね
偉大なる状態になりましたと
普通のレベルより大きいスケールになりましたという心
ですから 日本語で大心なんですね
簡単に 大心 いわゆるレベル高い心ということです
レベル高い認識と ですから大心は一般の人にはない
今まで我々が喋ったのは普通の常識的な心ですけど
これから喋るものは科学的じゃない
ああだこうだとか そんな嘘
そんなどうでもいいことを言ったって何の意味もないんです
一般常識的な心じゃないと
大心 大きくなった心の世界
それはあり得るかないかということは
一つの方法で説明できるんです
我々には目があって 目で物は見える
それは制限があるんです
何が見えるかと もし工夫してその制限を変えれば違うものを見る
何のこともないんです
人間よくやってるんだから
例えば遠いところのものは見えませんでしょ？人間には
でも望遠鏡を使えば見えると
我々には小さいものはどれぐらいの小さいもの見えるかということは決まってるんです
零点何ミリか僕は勉強してないんだからわかりませんだけど
一応論理的には知ってるんです
1 ミリのものは見えるし
0.5 ミリのものも見えるし
そういう風に言って まあもしかするとまあ0 0.005 だったら見えないかもしれません
1000 分の 1 ミリの 1000 分の 1 ぐらいは見えないかもしれません
ですから どれぐらいの大きいものは見えるかということは
人間の場合は決まってるんです
でも顕微鏡を使えばかなり見える
それでも顕微鏡を使ってもナノミリのものは見えません
そこで あのあれ どんな顕微鏡っていうんですか
あのエレクトロニック
電子顕微鏡 そこで電子顕微鏡でナノミリのものも見えるんだと言ってるだけで見えてないんです
見えない ですから 電子顕微鏡を使っても見えないものは見えない
今はちゃんと原子は見えますよと写真まで撮ってますけど
それは目で見たことじゃないんです
決して あくまでも計算して作った画像なんです
電波望遠鏡で遠いところのもの見えるかというと
全然見えません 電波を受けて
それなりに計算してコンピューターで画像を作るんです
それと実体見えたわけじゃないんです
ですから 顕微鏡で見えるのはちゃんと目で見えるんです
ですから 顕微鏡の倍率のギリギリのところは
人間に見えるギリギリのところなんです
電子顕微鏡で見えるところは人間に見えるところじゃないんです
それはそれから推測の世界
でも科学ではそれも見えてるんだというふうに言ってるようかもしれませんだけど
僕ら仏教の人から言えば
電子顕微鏡では本物は見えないと
ということは ちょっと工夫すると普段見えないものは見えるということなんですね
音を使っても 例えばこの部屋の中にある音を全部我々に聞こえません
でも ものすごい感度は鋭い
マイクロフォンで音を拾ってみたら
耳に聞こえない音は聞こえるようになる
そういうふうなことで
ですから 工夫すれば 認識は認識のレベルを次元を上に持っていくことは可能ということなんです
ですから ある面で顕微鏡で物を見るということも
一つの神通力のようなものなんですね
道具を使ってやってるんだから
人間は成長しなくても見えると
でもほんのちょっとの訓練は必要なんですね
特に原子顕微鏡で物を見る場合は
もうかなり勉強してないと電子顕微鏡の扱い方はわかりません
ほんのちょっと教えてあげれば
顕微鏡の扱い方はわかると
望遠鏡にしてだっても
普通の望遠鏡だったら僕にでも見えますけど
すごい倍率が高いプロ用のものだったらちょっとわからないんですね
使い方 それなりに勉強しなきゃ
ですから ある訓練さえあれば
まあ認識のレベルが高くはなるんです
じゃあなんでこのマハッガタチット
あるいは大心に一番初めにルーパが散ると言うんですかと
こういう意味なんですね
心のレベルが高くなったんだけど
物質に物質に依存している
物質を認識しているんです
物質的な次元を超えてないんです
いわゆる心と物質 ナーマとルーパが未だにくっついているんです
で 心を一応物質と一緒に